touché mais pas encore coulé considéré
encore comme une bonne élève de la
gestion de la pandémie au printemps
dernier l'allemagne est désormais
frappée de plein fouet par la pandémie
commis 19 économiquement d'abord après
une année 2009 un record pour la
récession depuis la crise financière de
l'allemagne voit son pib reculer de 5%
mais reste sauve grâce au rebond de son
secteur industriel et celle de
l'économie allemande a chuté de 5%
l'année dernière
c'est un record dramatique le fait que
ce soit inférieur de près d'un pour cent
aux craintes que nous avions au début de
la première phase de la pandémie est une
faible consolation à dreux
côté sanitaire l'allemagne fait face à
un rebond important de l'épidémie covit
19 sur son territoire malgré un
confinement par celle en vigueur depuis
le mois de décembre la fermeture des
commerciaux on est essentielle celle des
bars et des restaurants ou autres lieux
de culture depuis le mois de novembre
l'allemagne a enregistré ce mercredi
plus de 25 mille nouveaux cas de kobe de
19 ans 24 heures 1244 décès ont
également été recensés face à ces
chiffres et à l'apparition des nouveaux
variants anglais et sud africain du
coronavirus présents sur le territoire
allemand
les autorités sanitaires s'alarme et
appel à prendre des mesures conséquentes
pour la lutte contre la pandémie jugeait
trop laxiste jusqu'à présent il est
possible que la situation s'aggrave
encore il est donc d'autant plus
important que les mesures soient
systématiquement respecter nous devons
éviter que ces nouveaux variants ne se
répande fort bragg 6 en février ou mars
nous allégeons un peu les restrictions
nous aurons second trimestre une forte
croissance comme cet été l'espoir donc
de voir l'économie rebondir au deuxième
trimestre 2021
mais pour cela des décisions exigeante
vis-à-vis de la population devrait être
prise dans les jours prochains en gala
merkel a averti les prochaines semaines
devraient constituer la phase la plus
dure
la pandémie la chancelière
s'entretiendra avec les dirigeants les
16 länder le 25 janvier pour tenter
d'endiguer la pandémie outre-rhin
à ce jour huit cent quarante deux mille
personnes ont été vaccinées contre le
coc vite 19 en allemagne soit 1% de la
population